FOR HIS NEW INVENTION.
- IT'S GOOD, Y'ALL.
LIKE, GREETINGS AND SALUTATIONS.
YO, YO, BUT LET ME, LIKE,
ASK YOU THIS, THOUGH.
LIKE, WHAT KEEPS YOU
FROM GETTING WET IN THE RAIN
WHEN IT'S, LIKE, WET?
- UMBRELLA.
- AN UMBRELLA.
- RIGHT, I [bleep] WITH THAT,
BUT, LIKE,
WHAT KEEPS THE UMBRELLA
FROM GETTING WET?
BOOM, YOU SEE THAT?
THAT'S THE TOP UMBRELLA,
AND IT--IT KEEP
THE BOTTOM UMBRELLA NICE AND DRY
SO YOU'RE, LIKE, NOT WET
WITH THE--YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- THE SECOND UMBRELLA
IS GONNA BE WET.
- RIGHT.
- WHY DO YOU NEED TO KEEP
THE UNDER UMBRELLA DRY?
- HONESTLY, LIKE, IMAGINE
YOU'RE WITH A BITCH, RIGHT?
SHE GOT THE MOTHER[bleep] CLAP
AND ALL THAT.
MY [bleep] STEVE CAUGHT THAT,
BUT LIKE, HAD HE HAD
TWO CONDOMS,
THE FIRST ONE WOULDA BROKE,
SECOND ONE,
HE WOULDA BEEN ALL GOOD.
- OKAY, SO THIS IS
A CUMBERSOME PHYSICAL METAPHOR
FOR SEXUAL MISFORTUNE?
- LIKE, HONESTLY, LIKE,
THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
- I AM PREPARED TO INVEST
THE FULL 5 MILLION.
- THAT'S WHAT'S UP, MAN.
narrator: NEXT UP IS JEFF,
A DISGRACED NBA REFEREE.
- OKAY.
YOU GUYS HAVING FUN TODAY?
- YEAH.
- LOT OF GOOD PITCHES.
- YES, YES.
- YEAH.
- YOU GUYS LOCK IN PLANS
FOR AFTERWARDS, OR...
OOF.
- UH, I'M SORRY?
- DID YOU GUYS
LOCK IN PLANS FOR--
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE DONE
SHOOTING, OR--
- I'M PROBABLY
JUST GONNA GO HOME.
- THIS IS NOT NERVES.
I'M COMPLETELY COMFORTABLE
IN THIS SITUATION.
- IT APPEARS
EXACTLY LIKE NERVES.
- YEAH.
A LOT OF PRO ATHLETES
GET OUT THERE,
THEY'RE BIG BROTHERS,
BIG SISTERS,
STUFF LIKE THAT, OKAY,
BUT THERE'S NO MONEY IN THAT,
RIGHT?
SO HERE'S THE PITCH.
IT'S LIKE A--
IT'S CALLED "HANG TIME,"
OKAY?
YOU GUYS, PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES
GO AND HANG OUT,
NOT WITH KIDS,
BUT WITH COOL ADULTS.
- UH, I'M A HARD "NO."
- DANTE?
- NO WAY IN HELL, OR HELL NO.
TAKE IT EITHER WAY YOU WANT IT.
- ALL RIGHT, I'LL CHOOSE
THAT ONE ON MY--ON MY OWN TIME.
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
- MATTEUS?
- YOU SEEM TERRIBLE
AND YOUR BODY CONFUSES ME.
- ALL RIGHT.
NO.